In this lesson, you created two plots for conditional
means. Let's take a closer look at both of the
plots and see how they're different. This second block of
code gave us this plot. And this first block of
code gave us this plot. Now, you subset this data
frame to only consider uses who are age 71 or
less. So, let's do the same up here. Running the
code, we can see that we're limiting our x axis.
Now, what I want to do is put these two plots
side by side so we can look at them together. Now,
you know this before, we basically just say, each plot into
a variable, and then we plot those variables in one column.
So, here's the difference between age and age with months.
By decreasing the size of our bins and increasing the number
of bins, we have less data to estimate each conditional mean.
We can see that the noise is a lot worse on
this graph since we have finer bin choices. On the other
hand, we could go the other direction and increase the size
of the bins. Say, we could lump everyone together whose age
falls under a multiple of five. Essentially what we'll do is, we'll
cut our graph in pieces and average these mean friend counts
together. So, users who are within two and a half years
of 40 will get lumped into one point. The same will
be true for users who are within two and a half years
of 50 and for users who are in two and a half
years of 60. I'll show you what I mean in code. Here,
I'm creating a plot with age that's been divided by five, rounded
and then multiplied by five. I've also subsetted our data frame, just
like the other plots. The last thing I'll do is I'll add
a geom line with a stat summary. I don't really want to
plot the friend count, I want to plot the mean friend count.
So I'll pass summary to stat, and I'll pass mean to fun.y.
I'll save this plot, and add it in with the
others. So, see how we have less data points here? And
wider bin widths. By doing this, we would estimate the
mean more precisely, but potentially miss important features of the age
and friend count relationship. These three plots are an example
of the bias variance tradeoff, and it's similar to the tradeoff
we make when choosing the bin width in histograms. One way
that analysts can better make this trade off is by using
a flexible statistical model to smooth our estimates of
conditional means. ggplot makes it easier fit such models using
geom smooth. So, instead of seeing all this noise,
we'll have a smooth modular function that will fit along
the data. We will do the same for this
plot as well. Here, I've added the geom smooth layer
to both our first plot and our second plot. I'm
just using ggplot's defaults so all the decisions about what
model we'll be using will be made for us.
If you're interested in exploring the models and the parameters,
take a look at the geom smooth documentation. So, I'll
save these two plots and then I'll run the code
again. So, here's our smoother for age_with_months, and here's our
smoother for age. While the smoother captures some of the
features of this relationship, it doesn't draw attention to the
non-motonic relationship in the low ages well. Not only that,
but it really misses the discontinuity at age 69.
This highlights that using models like LOESS or
smoothing splines can be useful. But, like nearly any
model, it can be subject to systematic errors, when
the true process generating our data isn't so consistent
with the model itself. Here the models are based
on the idea that true function is smooth. But,
we really know that there's some discontinuity in the relationship.